he celebrated his birthday we had a good
time Kris Jenner opens up about Rob
Kardashian's at 29 to feed a talk to me
about that celebration it was a cute
photo of the entire bag of fun he
celebrated his birthday and we had a
good time and we picked a night that
most all of us could be in one place at
the same time oh he was missing from the
phone where yep she's working and then
she was sick and she's had a crazy yeah
so I I'm not even sure was she working
in or out of town he's just so great
want to keep track right well it is the
rub looks Rob looks so happy you must be
so happy for et caught up with Chris at
the fashion Los Angeles awards sunday
night so is there added pressure when
you're coming to a fashion event you're
gonna be rubbing elbows but call
waterfowl and Kate Hudson you know what
I think you have to wear what feels good
and feel good about yourself and you
know over the years I've made so many
fashion mistakes you know you just have
to roll with it hope you know you feel
good about yourself and where would you
want is there one regrettable look that
sticks out your mind from the palace
there's many I can't even list them and
I do know that when I wear something
just really classic and pretty from one
of my favorite designers that I can't go
wrong